we're going to have a look at this
question together and you might have
some kind of memories from we did a very
similar style of question but with
logarithmic functions back when we were
doing exponentials and logs so we're
going to sort of work our way through
this and i want to point out a few
things not just in your answer but in
how we set it out okay so let's have a
start
they provide you with this function y
equals 10 2x and then the first task is
i'm looking for a tangent okay one of
the things i hope you remember
is that when we are dealing with
trigonometric functions we have these
two different kinds of units we can put
in right you could put degrees you could
put radians now what you will find is
that in all of these questions where
there's a derivative of a trigonometric
function involved you will see these x
equals pi on eight business right this
is in radians now this is a really
important note to make in fact if you've
got another color then highlight this
and make it make a big song and dance
about it okay
whenever you are in the world of
calculus
and doing trigonometry okay
in calculus we are always dealing in
radians always in radians so let's just
highlight that
you guys know if you reach for your
calculator right now
i'd love you actually to pull it open
and one of the things you'll notice is
you know you can change the mode of your
calculator from degrees to radians
and if you do something like say
sine
30 and you hit equals right the
calculator will do radically different
things based on whether you're in
radians or degrees just a quick show of
hands
open your calculator up don't fiddle
with it whose calculator is currently in
degrees hands up
the vast majority of you okay think is
down um some of you might be in radians
already and if you're not we're going to
change shortly but for those of you who
just raise your hand when you see sine
30 and you press equals what does your
calculator tell you
it tells you a half because sine of 30
degrees this is like one of those
important exact values sine of 30
degrees is a half it's really easy to
remember however if you now go ahead
change the mode of your calculator
change it into radians and then i want
you to do exactly the same thing i want
you to type in sine 30.
now it'll give you something weird right
i actually don't know what it's going to
give you can someone tell me yeah
negative 0.98
yeah eight 8.
nine eight okay you're sure thank you
dot dot okay now
the reason why you're getting these
different results of course
is that this is now saying sine of 30
radians
sine of 30 radians so rather than 30
degrees can you do me a favor guys put
your pens down
can you make a 30 degree angle roughly
between your hands tell me what you
think that looks like i just want to say
can you hold up for me as well i just
want to see
okay very good all right now have a
think about this
what would 30 radians look like in
comparison to this
yeah we're in trouble right now can you
do that again what did you you did
something with your hands that kind of
like said
correct so when we think in radians
right a full revolution is how many
radians
2
2 pi which is 6.28 right so if this was
some multiple of 6.28 that's how many
times it goes around a full circle hence
keegan doing that weird thing with his
hand okay so eventually it spins round
and round and round whatever four or
five times and it winds up here strange
but okay
now this is important i want you to go
back to in fact i hope some of you stuck
it in when we were introducing the
trigonometric derivatives like couple
lessons back right what did i hand you i
handed you something that we measured
what was it
it was the sign graph right and now look
at the scale and i highlighted this
right at the start but i'm highlighting
it again now it's in
radians right and we measured we're like
oh this gradient is 1. this gradient is
0.5 if it was all in degrees the scale
would be totally off so every
trigonometric derivative you will
encounter it's always in radians
sometimes they make it super obvious
like here
x equals pi on eight you're like oh
obvious radians but other times it's not
obvious you can know it'll always be in
those units
all right where did i put mark here it
is
that was a bit of a prelude now let's
actually go to work right
to get the derivative sorry to get the
gradient of the tangent we need the
derivative right so can someone help me
out
with d y on dx what are we gonna get in
this case
very good two sec
squared now what comes next
in the back of your mind you might be
doing chain rule right this thing here
is the u
as it were okay now the components that
you've got are here's the
u dash
tan turns into sec squared the next
thing that happens is you put back u
so it should just be
2x whatever is there comes along for the
ride does that make sense
girls are you right are you looking for
someone
you okay
we had a room change so yeah thank you
i'm good
all right now we have a derivative this
is the gradient function what am i going
to do with it
yeah go ahead keegan
yeah fantastic i think i heard on the
front as well okay um this x value is
going to go into there and that will
give us the gradient at a particular
point so i'm going to say at x equals pi
on 8
m there's my gradient equals and i'm
just going to go ahead right 2
sec squared that 2x will become pi on
4. so far so good now of course your
calculator does not have a sec button on
it it's one over
cos so it might be helpful for you to
say oh this is two on cos square
pi on four you could punch this into
your calculator but i think we can do a
little bit better than that
not just
well you'll see why in a second
cos pi on four
that's cos of
45 degrees this is another one of those
exact values does anyone know what cos
of pi on 4 is off the top of their head
yeah go ahead
1 over root 2 very good so i've got 2
over
1 on root 2
squared you can see that's squared that
squared so far so good
so what i've got here is 2 divided by
it's been squared so it's a half
what's the answer i'm getting up
this is
4. this is a gradient apparently okay
now just before i go any further let's
just have a think does this make sense
this is the graph i'm interested in y
equals 10 2x
i want you to have a mental image of
this graph we're about to draw it
actually i'm pretty sure the question
asks us too shortly
what does 10 x look like forget about
the two for a second can you with your
hand i'll give you a clue it starts from
the origin what does tan x do
it just kind of
it goes up and it just gets steeper and
steeper and steeper why does it get so
steep
it goes toward a
asymptote right so just kind of
skyrockets like that okay now what does
that two in there do
it actually makes it it's really tricky
right this one actually makes it even
steeper it compresses it so if you want
to use the language of dilation that you
might remember from last year this is
actually the way i think about it is
don't worry about drawing this for now
we'll draw a full version later
we would normally say from naught to two
pi this is how much
of the tan curve you would get
that's how much you would
reach at the end of two pi
now this 2 means you get twice as much
of it right so in fact you get this and
then you get it again
from 0 to 2 pi so it's like all squashed
in does that make sense so in other
words like you told me it was quite
steep
when i squash it in it's going to get
even steeper hence this is a pretty
steep gradient makes sense always so
important you get a result don't just
walk off do a sense check on it and see
if it's reasonable
okay what am i going to do with this
i've just gotten to m
that's not the answer
where do i put it
yeah i'm looking for a point gradient
when i'm looking for a tangent i've got
a gradient i've got half of a point
right here so how do i get the other
half yeah rishi
yeah now i put x into but where do i put
it in i've already put in here
i'm now gonna have to put it into
yeah the original one can you go ahead
and tell me once you put that in
what why equals else
daniel and christian
lecture theater now does it say who is
from
yeah
okay
okay no worries cursed you people who
are excellent swimmers dan did you hear
that yeah okay uh you don't seem to be
in a hurry to like get moving
okay wait is christian
yeah you well do you guys want to go
together i'll um i'll finish this off
and then we can um see how far you guys
can get someone got a y value for me
anyone
it's ten of
pi on four
45 degrees that's one it's another one
of these exact
values so i've got that
here's an x here's why so now i'm going
to put this into as suggested point
gradient
oh great question so when you put in the
x value do you put it in radians or
degrees
this whole world that we're living in at
the moment it's like i'm in i'm in
calculus town right so it's a little bit
like you know you go to a new part of
the world you're like are we metric or
imperial here it's like similar kind of
thing with calculus so make sure you're
in radians for everything okay
all right has anyone already got ahead
of me the
tangent
is going to be y minus
y one
so which is which is one and then what
do i get on the right hand side
m which in this case is four
and x
minus
x one which was provided right at the
beginning so it's pi
on
8.
strictly speaking that is the equation
but we could tidy it up a little bit
right what are we going to get y equals
over here
4x
take away
pi on two and then i'll add one to get
it all over here on the right hand side
okay
all right i'm pretty satisfied with that
let's have a look at what p p b asks us
to do we're looking for two intercepts
right so this is part b
now one of the advantages of writing it
in this form is that one of the
intercepts is just sitting right there
you don't have to do any work which
intercept is it
it's the y intercept right
there it is right there okay that's the
y intercept so
you just kind of get that one for free
how do i get the x intercept out of it
yeah i'll let y equal to zero here it is
over here and then i want to make x the
subject so oops wrong color when i work
that out has anyone already got there
i will let y equal zero
like so
you could do it anywhere that you like
but if i do it say
here i've got 4 outside of x minus pi on
8 equals negative 1
divide through
by 4
and then i'm going to add to both sides
so i guess that would be 0.18
you satisfied with that i mean you may
have put it into here we should
hopefully get the same answer yeah
there's the x-intercept there's the
y-intercept now i want to see how far
you can get on this sketch i already
kind of gave you a little bit of a leg
up this is what tan x roughly looks like
you don't need to draw the whole thing
just a small part of it
sketch it and then see if you can come
up with the particular triangle that
they're after there's an area that they
want us to calculate okay let me give
you a minute to work on your own off you
go